hey I'm Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith today our guest he is the one and
only the very funny comedian Andrew
Santino hey I'm Andrew Santino this is
do it again no feeling there's gonna be
a little bit funnier than normal cuz
you're funnier than Christian so I'm not
true normally you have your buddies in
here Andrew and I go way back
away but I have my buddy here today it's
true but I have a feeling just from us
hanging out upstairs that your
friendship is not like the nice
supportive kind it's the like break you
down kinda it's like my father will give
me a glass of water dad does not like my
father
I mean it's body similar but other than
that yeah my Comedy Central special
comes out November 27th on Comedy
Central right after Kevin Hart's so
please stick around please we'll see all
the one but you're also a movie fanatic
yes I've known that about you for a long
time as well two out of the movies
you've seen so far this year give me a
couple your favorites well inside out
was my favorite movie of the year hands
down I cried I cried three or four times
I didn't cry when my grandma died but I
cried that inside out there's no shame
no I didn't I just was like oh she's
gone but inside out oh my god I cried
this is going on the internet right but
I know that you worked in film
production before you got it - yeah I
did I was a PA like an AP but I did I
did it all I don't know why go away from
film and into a comedy because I'm a
miserable person inside and I that's the
only way to get it out - yes - get on
you know I do yeah you know that's why
she's so happy
yeah she's away from it this is becoming
a therapy session it is that's the
reason I brought him here yeah I need to
get through some stuff Andrew you know I
have a gambling problem yeah absolutely
we do a weekly wager on the show or tick
and I will put our butts on the line and
we bet on the box off
yeah that's all last week
for the movie Maze Runner yes for strike
and you wagered 41 million right Tiffany
wagered 43 million and we can see from
the graphic behind us graphics on this
show we don't talk about there's a full
screen graphic Tiffany right here
according to the box office total it was
thirty point three million which any
sort of deductive math comes to the
conclusion that you Tiffany are a loser
I didn't win this week's wager I will
admit it
yeah but see how nicely I did oh nice
nice I got Selena Gomez here to tell you
that you lost please tell Tiffany Smith
that she lost once again but did she
lose I mean I decided to I got you girl
whatever this week's loser should comes
from one of our YouTube viewers the
geekness overlord
who says loser should and every sentence
with just like in that movie and she has
to say the name of the movie related to
what they said I'm gonna try really hard
just like in that movie Rudy
okay I'll give it to no give it to why
don't we do some bets for this week
Hotel Transylvania the first movie was a
surprise hit the second one comes out
this weekend I think that's only bet on
and because of it I'm going 37 million
for this okay I am going to go with 36
million which is right underneath of
what you bet I know just like in that
movie
Pocahontas that's kind of dirty and
weird know that ad that's true yeah
that's it yeah I got to tell you that's
true that's in there make sure you
hashtag this up make sure you hashtag
loser should on YouTube on Facebook and
make sure you include what's got to
happen to the other person in great
detail alright don't forget on Twitter
cuz that's there too would be really
funny to take a look at some of the
polls that Fandango does and this one
that we want to talk about are the worst
movies that you can watch on a plane and
we're talking about polls so just like
in that movie showgirls yeah now before
we get into the poll let's actually is
there one that pops off to you do you
think I wouldn't want to watch on the
plane Malibu's Most Wanted no no it's
got it's got to be part of something do
a plane or plane crash Oh
flight flights like some probably the
best one because it's yeah one of the
whole movies about a plane crash upside
down yeah I would assume that's the
worst one to watch I stand by my
Malibu's Most Wanted being a bad movie
to watch it on the plane and why you
think if you want to jump off the plane
just cuz I have why would you watch that
right there's got to be something else
on that thing good point you know
there's got to be another one to see
there's got to be so many more options
and if that's the one you watch it's
like what's going on man you guys want
to check out the full list just go with
two fandango.com and check it out but
some of the movies that stand out to me
when I'm looking at it snakes on a plane
die hard to an airplane I think that's
one of the funniest movies of all time
okay we're gonna yeah we'll stay on
track just thinking that movie star wars
so you really like airplane did you know
that it's actually spoof based off of
another movie I didn't I did air for it
1975 look at this scene here this is the
same airplane a lot of people don't
realize is that airplanes actually a
direct parody of the movie zero hour
which came out in 1957 the sucker
brothers actually bought the rights to
this movie this movie is a hardcore
drama as where airplane is anything but
a drum everyone loves this scene but you
got a wife watch the difference there is
no difference between this film and zero
guys Harris I mean they get but this was
the point this is you can't look at this
movie and say it's a ripoff because they
market their rights yeah you ever seen a
grown man naked so there you go some of
you may have known that already about
the zero hour and airplane but even if
you didn't now you can go there and
check it out on YouTube there are
mashups it's pretty awesome so all this
talk about planes we didn't do game time
last week so we wanted to mix it up this
week and play with some toys are you
guys ready
excited before we start Tiffany I just
like to thank Andrews brother for
joining us today as our live audience
what are we doing - okay so we should
get one shot to land our toy airplanes
as close to the toy landing zone over
there and whoever gets the closest gets
to spend the winners wheel Oh points
alright okay ladies first
all right yep
I was horrible I think that I'll be able
to beat - yeah all right one audience
member OH
overshot it overshot it all right you
just got to get that consent he know do
it let's see
dun dun dun dun dun upside down landing
injury wins and it is time to spin the
winners will of winning $1 all right so
you got here which means you get to rant
on whatever you want for 10 seconds are
you ready yep I'd like to talk about the
guys that introduced the movies and the
movie theater that say hey what's up
welcome to so and so I don't need you to
tell me I'm gonna see movie I know what
movie I'm here to see leave me alone go
away and I'm in a sense you know thanks
bye Andrea
I gotta get validated or I'll throwing
at him thank you so much
I was gonna say thanks stander Santino
but he was saying thank you to himself
check out war from him follow them on
social media Cheetos Santino and
definitely check out his Comedy Central
special on November 27 and as all who
comes out the same day say no more yes
and make sure that you guys check out
some more of our videos which are right
there actually I subscribe to the
channel right there and then download
the Fandango movie clips app on your
smartphone join us next week on a
threesome
you